hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
msnbc is still completely insane
well it was one of the major stories to
emerge from the 2020 election it was the
shift we saw
in the hispanic vote democrats still won
the hispanic vote in 2020 you could see
by 21 points but that was down 17 points
from 2016. hillary clinton won the
hispanic vote by 38 joe biden by just 21
and you know what the trend seems to be
continuing in 2022 what you're looking
at here this is the average of every
poll we've got out there that's been
taken over the last three months that
looks at the hispanic vote and you put
them all together hispanics are now
voting democratic by just 13 points so
from 38 to 21 now down in the 2022
midterm polling to a democratic
advantage of just 13 points what's going
on here our next guest rui tashira
co-wrote the emerging democratic
majority back in 2002 it argued that a
diversifying electorate including the
growth of the hispanic electorate could
make democrats the majority party of the
21st century two decades later now
though rui tashira is now arguing that
quote working class and hispanic voters
are losing interest in the party of
abortion gun control and the january 6th
hearings and rui tashira joins us now
thank you rory for joining us um
it's interesting i feel like i've been
hearing for years maybe even decades
that hispanic there were certain issues
that republicans could offer sort of as
a bridge to hispanic voters there was
potential for republicans with hispanic
voters
and yet it really seems that it was
during donald trump's presidency that we
started to see this significant movement
that's continuing now why did it why did
it start now
well that's a good question and i think
a lot of democrats are asking themselves
exactly that question i mean it seems
almost hard to believe right i mean
donald trump donald trump the guy who
said the things he did about immigrants
and was uh you know borderline or
actually racist
in a lot of ways at least in his
pronouncements
i think a lot of democrats assume that
that should
send hispanics hurtling in the democrats
direction so they wouldn't carry them by
38 points as clinton did in in 2016 but
rather by 45 points in fact as you
pointed out steve exactly to the reverse
happened there was a a
you know very very large drop in the
democratic advantage among hispanics it
was true nationally it was true in
almost all states
and we see moving into the 2022 election
that it's probably getting
worse some polls have hispanics
basically just tied
between republicans and democrats and
the generic congressional this is uh you
know in the last uh off-year election
hispanics probably voted for democrats
by about 35 points so something happened
that's sending them away from the
democrats and my theory is
that there's a couple of important
things here one is that i think
democrats assumed that
hispanics because their people of color
were sort of all in on this racial
reckoning that we had in the summer of
2020 around george floyd and that
generally they could be treated as a
group that is very very sensitive to
these issues of race very very sensitive
to uh the kinds of the dialogue around
that uh and
that's sort of very sensitive the issue
of immigration for example which was
something that democrats always thought
they had a big advantage on and i think
in the process
democrats have lost track of the fact
that this
as i put it hispanic voters are normie
voters they're voters who are concerned
with upper mobility with jobs healthcare
their communities their kids you know
effective schools public safety these
are these are voters who thought the
democrats could be relied upon to do a
good job uh in those respects and who
could be counted on
even if they're more liberal in the
other party not to be so liberal that it
would turn off uh people whose values
were were significantly more
conservative than where democrats seemed
to be coming from and all of that got
lost i think in the transition from 2016
to 2020 and where we see the democrats
going today where they become far far
more socially liberal the whole variety
of issues which do not in fact comport
well with the media and hispanic voter
especially especially the median working
class hispanic voter because if you look
at the data that's clearly where they're
losing most of their support among
working class hispanics